I won't you don't get involved involved
they're not involved do you remember
Redbeard hey youtubers it's Charlie so
everyone's been asking me for my
breakdown for saina 3 so here it is I
found a bunch of good references in
clues so I also decided to include a few
theories based on those clues and since
I posted my Q&A video Stephen Moffat and
Mark Gatiss have started talking about
series 4 and series 5 I'll be talking
about that after I post my episode 3
videos next week so be sure to subscribe
to get everything
I'll be doing series 4 predictions and
there will be a lot of fun stuff going
on
get excited though the minute they said
series 5 I just thought 2 more years of
Sherlock I'll be analyzing very specific
parts of the plot of Simon 3 so if you
haven't seen it yet be careful because
this will be super spoilery so everybody
grab your eyeball tea and let's get
started number 1 happy birthday Sherlock
so it's not exactly part of the episode
but the Monday after this episode aired
was the hundred and sixtieth birthday of
the Sherlock Holmes character he doesn't
look a day over 30
number two the red-headed league the
game that Lestrade and Donovan are
chasing in the opening scenes is a
reference to the red-headed league also
denoted by the red heading on the
newspaper article in Holmes Canon the
league was a ruse created by thieves as
a way to distract authorities one of the
bank robbers from the original story is
even named Archie which is the same name
as the little boy
Sherlock promised to show those pictures
to at the wedding 3 the best theory I've
seen about the gang is that one of them
is a member of Scotland Yard with the
strawed which is how they're staying one
step ahead and that there are a
combination of those three gunmen from
Reichenbach Fall if you look at the
pictures of each of them they look
somewhat similar to mrs. Hudson Watson
and Lestrade is gunman we don't see the
one that looks like Lestrade is gunmen
at the crime scene but it's implied that
he was there he was actually the one who
kidnapped the little girl who screamed
at Sherlock see how much he looks like
that person walking into the school
while Sherlock was mine palace' just to
reinforce that point
doesn't he look amazingly like the
person in the background working with
Lestrade during the case we can assume
that he's the one that's the Inside Man
tipping off the bank robbers number four
when Donovan tells Lestrade that Jones
will get all the credit it's a book
reference to offend Lee Jones from the
original book sign of four during that
book Jones arrested a family but it
turned out to be wrong so the water
skank that they mentioned in this
episode is being falsely accused
so it's just another piece of evidence
that these people were Moriarty's gunmen
and they're now just working for the
villain Charles Augustus Magnussen I'm
expecting episode 3 to pay off this bank
robber plot number 5
there's blackmail afoot the villain
Magnussen is based on the book character
Charles Augustus Milverton a master
blackmailer here's where things get a
little weird with these bank robbers
notice that really old looking one
there's actually conspiracy theory that
this gang member is actually Mary
morstan's father and mary has been
living under a false name and the
villain has been using her father's
criminal identity as a means to
blackmail her think about what Sherlock
saw when he deduced her she's a liar
she had a guardian and she has a secret
during saina 3 she talks about being an
orphan but what if she's lying about
that and about her name number 6 more
evidence that Mary's real father is one
of those bank robbers in the original
book sine of 4 Mary's father was
involved with the stolen treasure plot
inside a three that treasure is just
replaced with the bank old number 7
mary's guardian was Charles Augustus
Magnussen the person who centered the
telegram is addressed kam that
abbreviation kam was also used by the
book villain Milverton which Magnussen
is based on my mind has been blown
number 8 Magnussen is trolling married
the telegram the kam sent said
specifically wish your family could have
seen this note that in the timeline of
the episode the wedding is the day after
the final bank robber scene on that day
Donovan was on her way to arrest those
people so Mary's real father could have
been in jail during the wedding I know a
lot of people believe that Mary will die
in episode 3 but if her father does
exist and he's one of these bank robbers
he could be the Morstan that ends up
dying number 9 the papers fluttering
when lost rods backup arrives at Baker
Street are the beginnings of Sherlock's
waltz for John and Mary he's been
working on that for a long time also
note when he's dancing to that waltz
later that you actually learned that
Sherlock loves to dance and even taught
Watson how to dance
I wonder what mrs. Hudson thought
whenever she walked in on the two of
them number 10 mrs. Hudson's private
life we learned that mrs. Hudson's
husband was executed for committing
double homicide and that he was a drug
dealer in Florida every time I look at
her now I think of Skylar White from
Breaking Bad number eleven Sherlock
Holmes wedding planner
Sherlock's nature mislead you into
thinking that he'd be a terrible best
man but because he's trying so hard to
integrate into John and Mary's new
life he goes extremely overboard and
managing almost every detail of their
wedding from vetting the guest list to
helping plan the seating chart to
folding napkins into origami opera
houses he really wants to be a part of
this new family number 12
Sherlock is amazing with children in the
original stories Holmes employed and
took care of neighborhood children
called the Baker Street Irregulars
previously on the show that group had
just been replaced by Sherlock's
homeless Network
just imagine Sherlock helping raise John
and Mary's baby number 13
Sherlock is Peter Pan also during the
scenes with Archie Sherlock mentions
that he'll ask grown-up he need that he
doesn't think of himself as a grown-up
that's another reference to the origins
of the character being something of a
Peter Pan figure always looking for
adventure remember that most of the
original Holmes stories had the word
adventure in them number fourteen major
character development
Sherlock seeking to make attachment is a
big deal in this episode notice him
asking Mary about John's relationship
with major Sholto later he argues with
Mycroft about caring being an advantage
and my craft advisory meeting involved
he's just trying to find out where he
fits in John's new life number 15 red
beard so many people had questions about
this but the best theory I've seen
supports the idea that when Mycroft
mentions red beard he's actually
referencing Mary notice that he said red
beard twice during his phone call with
Sherlock red beard was actually a pirate
with his brother who continued being a
pirate after his brother died so on one
level it's a reference that Sherlock
will have to continue solving crimes
alone once Watson leaves him but here's
where it gets interesting
red beard had an adopted son named Eric
Lou Rouge Eric was a wealthy aristocrat
whose parents were killed and ended up
living under an assumed name but red
beard the pirate kept coming back into
his life asking him for help with new
schemes so what if Magnussen the master
blackmailer is the red beard in that
story that Mycroft is talking about and
he keeps blackmailing Mary Morstan who
in this case would be the Eric character
theory doesn't invoke the bank robber
plot that I mentioned earlier but
Margate is teased episode 3 by posting a
tweet that only said red beard meaning
that it is central to the plot of his
last vow everything is connected there
are no coincidences number 16 Mycroft
working out this is hilarious but in
addition to teasing my cross ring red
beard and Sherlock's childhood it's
also a reference to the original Mycroft
being described as very fat I already
discussed my cross ring in my Q&A video
so if you want to learn more about that
I'll add a link at the end of this video
number 17 Sherlock asked Mycroft to come
to the wedding again this ties into the
idea that Mycroft knows more about marry
than he's letting on and is advising
Sherlock not to get involved so he won't
be there whenever she comes between
Mycroft the government and Charles
Augustus Magnussen and does Sherlock's
last vow include protecting Mary from
Mycroft
notice how when the camera cuts back and
forth between them they each turn to
face away from each other number 18
Sherlock's toast the toast itself is the
backbone of the whole episode all the
other flashbacks and stories branch off
and come back to it but there are
several Canon references during it
namely Sherlock borrowing lines from
Watson I can't congratulate you from
scandal in Bohemia and then there's the
funny stories most of them were
references to things from sign of four
including the poison giant but then
there was the hollow client the
inexplicable matchbox the blanched
soldier the case of identity and the
vanishing elephant Mary's bridesmaid is
also a reference to the character Maude
Bellamy 19 molly is Sherlocks dana
scully
so this is kind of a stretch but during
Molly's montage she evokes imagery from
the x-files don't you think of her
relationship with Sherlock as being like
Mulder and Scully
drunk science for the win number 20 the
first telegram was from Mike Stanford
that's the person who introduced Watson
to Sherlock during study in pink 21
notice Mary's face whenever she says the
name cam reinforcing the idea that Mary
is afraid of him
also rewind to my numbers 5 through 7
for more evidence that she's being
blackmailed 22 Watson as Sherlock to be
his best man this was actually the scene
that they showed at comic-con notice
that Watson does not stop Sherlock from
drinking that eyeball t23
when Sherlock says sorry for that last
one that's his subtle way of apologizing
for faking his death 24 they're planning
the wedding at Baker Street under normal
circumstances they would plan the
wedding at Mary's but they want Sherlock
to be a part of their family so bad that
they bring the wedding to him 25
Sherlock is youtubing so this was funny
but it lets us know that Mary can deduce
emotions the same way Sherlock deduces
Clues she also can tell whenever
anyone's lying 26 the
guardsman is Dean Thomas from Harry
Potter 27
Watson's interaction with the military
commander reminds us about Watson's life
beyond Sherlock Holmes in the books most
of Sherlock's past is still a mystery
but we actually know quite a bit about
Watson number 28
Sherlock explains that he solves crimes
but it's Watson who saves lives it gives
you a good idea for how he thinks Watson
is so much more important than he is 29
the bar fight is a possible reference to
sign of four where Sherlock starts a
fight just to get information number 30
at the point they hit the stairs mrs.
Hudson reveals that they've only been
gone for two hours
31 am i the current king of England this
is a joke referencing the original
character in that character study there
was a picture of Queen Victoria on the
wall Benedict Cumberbatch's version even
shot Queen Victoria's initials into the
wall when he got bored number 32 the
game is something one of the best jokes
in the episode 33 the chatroom mind
palace so Sherlock deduces the mayfly
man by clueing for looks from the chat
room women the scene is beautifully shot
and incorporates some Freudian imagery
Sherlock is a very cerebral show and
Freud talked about the it'd the ego and
the super-ego in that courtroom
Mycroft represents the it'd the super
rational portion of Sherlock's brain
that helps him make decisions once he
starts to break down
Watson represents the super-ego the part
of his brain that deals with emotions
Sherlock himself represents the ego the
part that helps the it'd and the
super-ego communicate
that's why Mycroft at the end is yelling
at him to solve the case it's the
rational portion of his brain trying to
help him make deductions in case you
missed it all those women worked near
major Sholto 34 the cigarettes he's
hiding in his slipper are a reference to
the book Holmes hiding tobacco in his
Persian slippers 35 Sherlock is broken
Sherlock actually looks like he's
exhibiting signs of PTSD as his mind
palace hasn't been functioning at a
hundred percent on the series he also
has to physically abuse himself to focus
it's possible that something happened
that was very dark during those two
years he was alone and he hasn't dealt
with it yet 36 Sherlock's last vow he
vows to protect Watson's new family but
it sounds like that will eventually put
him in opposition to Mycroft and in the
books Watson did not have any children
which is a poor omen for episode three
last one 37 a doctor who reference
noticed that Sherlock leaving the
wedding early looks very similar to the
doctor trying to leave a mean rory's
wedding during the Big Bang it's another
case of a very strange man or Time Lord
depending on how you look at it trying
to leave when he feels he's the odd man
out
Amy and Rory chased after the doctor and
even though John and Mary didn't chase
Sherlock in this moment they've spent
the entire episode trying to make him
feel like he's part of their new family
so a lot of theories came out of me
cluing for all those looks most notably
Mary's real identity her relationship
with the villain and the identity of
those bank robbers
be sure to write it in the comments if
you didn't see anything I include in my
video I know there were a few things
that I kept out that I just put in my
Q&A that I didn't want to rehash one
really big idea that I'll end this video
on is the fact that series 3 ties up so
many plots going all the way back to
study in pink that means that series 3
on a larger level becomes the story of
everything on Sherlock so far just
meaning that Moriarty the bank robbers
the two bombing Mary and Charles
Augustus Milverton are all connected
somehow be sure to subscribe to get the
rest of my Sherlock videos my next one
will be my review of episode 3 that'll
post on Sunday after the episode airs
right now click here to learn more about
my crops wedding ring and click here to
get my review for Santa 3 thanks so much
for watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you